i think if you sum up the results of
the debates then you can
certainly say that we all want to have
the european borders and coastguards strengthened quickly and in a practical manner, of
course the agency also needs
the corresponding mandate for this and we
discussed very intensively today
how that will then be  what to look for in concrete
terms i found a broad consensus
in the debate, in particular
that everyone supports a strengthening of the role
of frontex in the area of ​​third countries
.
the same also applies to the area
of ​​support with regard to repatriation
and we need concrete
operational tasks and definitions for
this  frontex new or frontex
expanded and we then, above all,
also addressed the question of me
bindingly clarifying how
national sovereignty
behaves in cooperation with the
border protection agency, a financial boost
way from the states